Salut Romain qu'est que tu bois ?
Romain: Bah, du café
ahh
Attends qu'est que tu fais là
T'es pas en train de t'allumer une clope là
Romain: Bah, si
Nan Romain pose ce briquet tu sais ce que sa provoque chez toi
Romain non oh MON DIEU NOOOOON (bruit de volcan)
Génerique
Vous connaissez les trois C
Mais si: Café Clope Caca
La trilogie des matins qui chantent
Chant: Le soleil vient de se lever
Voilààà vous que vous voyez que vous connaissez
Mais est-ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé comment ça marche
Depuis la nuit des temps l'homme commence sa journée avec un bon café, une petite cibiche des familles et...
(bruit de défécation)
Siècles après siècles l'humanité a tenté de trouver une explication à ce prodige
Encore
Et encore
On a longtemps cru que le responsable était la caféine qui accélérait le péristaltisme. Vous savez ce mouvement des intestins qui accompagne le caca vers la sortie
Et puis un jour... Et puis un bon jour de 1999 le British Medical Channel publie une étude qui révèle que l'envie de déféquer le matin ce manifeste certes, chez les buveurs de café classique mais aussi, chez de décaféiné.
(gros caca)
La raison c'est que si la caféine semble effectivement avoir un effet sur le péristaltisme, le café caféiné ou pas augmente aussi l'activité motrice du colon sigmoïde
Alors sigmoïde c'est pas le prénom psy allemand c'est la partie la plus basse du colon celle qu'est relié au rectum vous savez, juste avant l'anus
Donc on comprend bien que quand ça remue par là on est assez tenté d'aller ce posé aux toilettes pour aller faire un peu de place
(bruit de prout)
Selon l'étude en question ça se manifeste entre 4 et 30 minutes après le café. Alors c'est important de savoir si on est plutôt team 4 minutes ou team 30 minutes
Pour pouvoir s'organiser
Je vais me chier dessus
Mais en réalité le phénomène est sans doute dû à plusieurs facteur
On sais par exemple que le café contient de l'acide clorogènique qui augmente qui augmente la production d'acide gastrique  ce qui pousse l'estomac à évacuer plus rapidement son contenu vers l'intestin
Bon ok mais la clope la dedans
Et bien si je vous disais que parmi les nombreuses substances contenus dans une cigarette il y en a une... La nicotine qui stimule le transit et accélère le Péristaltisme
Un... si je vous le disais... J'viens de vous le dire en faite
Romain: Ouaw
Merci Romain
Et oui la nicotine bouste votre transit et c'est même assez fréquent à l’arrêt de la cigarette d'être constipé et ballonné pendant quelque temps... voir pendant quelque semaines
Du coup l'association avec le café c'est... laxatif plus laxatif égal
Lave ton slip
(Je sais pas trop ce qu'il dit là)
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si vous aussi vous vous posez des questions existentiel de se genre facebook, twitter, les commentaires YouTube.
On se retrouve très bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo en attendant mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien.